it's what everyone in mexico wants for
christmas
the kovit vaccine and the one from fisa
has now finally arrived
as the phrase goes good things arrive in
small quantities
we have the privilege today of being one
of the first countries
in the world with a vaccine supply to be
handed out next year
and mexico is the first country in latin
america to get the vaccine
but for many people it won't be
available till the middle of next year
and meanwhile the country's in big
trouble
mexico city's hospitals are all but full
with very few ventilators left
there are queues outside shops selling
oxygen tanks
monica avalas traveled from another city
desperate to get one
like many people she's taking care of an
infected relative at home
we've come from toluca there's no oxygen
there
we went to two places but they didn't
have any till tomorrow
and i need it for today because my
patient my dad
can't go without oxygen
mexico never really got covert cases
down after the first wave
and now there's more than ever the
crowds in mexico city center throughout
december haven't helped
the government's just reluctantly
declared a red alert for the capital and
its suburbs
closing non-essential businesses but a
lot of people think
that authorities declared the alert for
the capital much too late
there's been questions over their
attitude towards a pandemic
from the beginning the mexican president
and the kovitsar rarely wear mars
and they've been accused repeatedly of
not imposing
timely and strict enough lockdowns
but the government has a powerful
counter argument mexico has more than
60 million poor people stopping them
from working could leave them destitute
especially since federal authorities
haven't rolled out a comprehensive
financial
plan to help them maria garcia is
selling face masks in the street
she says there's no way she could stay
home
of course not i'd be ashamed to hold out
my hand and say help me
that's why i'm here i get seven dollars
a day even if it's just to buy tortillas
instead the government's opted to try
and make sure that when people do get
sick
there's always a bed for them now for
the first time
it looks like that strategy could fail
although there were no queues waiting
outside of the six hospitals
that our team visited in mexico city
this week all of which were full
health experts say that could change
this january
john holman al jazeera mexico city